all of a sudden you know things uh
things start to go crazy you can either
accept that and go to places that you
just could never imagine when watching
the first season season five of Cobra
Kai brings us incredible sets fight
scenes with dangerous weapons legendary
characters from The Karate Kid world and
some hilarious behind-the-scenes mishaps
let's get into it
damn what are you doing here
I'm not sure number one things get a
little bit dark in this one and I got to
actually just spin around in a circle I
was so dizzy by the end of it something
unique about this show is that the
actors perform the majority of their own
stunts more on this later and then this
is my badass stunt devil silky hom who
I'm getting to fight against but they
also work and train alongside their
stunt doubles so everything looks as
natural as possible when they do need to
switch it was really fun to get to
actually play opposite her because we
train together so much to get Samantha's
Vibe right number two things got pretty
heated during this debate scene Devin
definitely does not suffer fools so
heated in fact that una O'Brien who
plays Devin had the prop team scrambling
for more copies of the death penalty for
her to rip I remember a lot of the takes
they asked me you know don't rip the
book this time but I just couldn't help
it she thought that scene really
showcased Devon's personality she just
has that physically aggressive Energy
number three 3 where Sam gets to go Toe
to Toe with herself the void was created
on COBRA Kai's second set of the Larusso
house not the one you can actually live
in but the one that was created on a
sound stage where the pool should be
that's where the void was set up and
you'll never guess what type of movie
Magic was used to set it up it was
basically just like these kind of like
rods that were hanging from the ceiling
holding like five black curtains and
circling back on how the actors do most
of their own stunts Mary Mouser was
going up against her own stunt double
selki hom in the black curtain void we
were in separate geese separate you know
Vibes hairstyles we had even different
like nail colors though this painted the
picture of dark Sam versus light Sam it
made the Practical aspect of shooting
incredibly difficult we literally had to
do like a full reset in order for selki
to be dark Sam and then light Sam I'm
supposed to be figuring out who I am and
for me to be dark salmon light Sam
number four the element of danger was
real with this one Thomas Ian Griffith
who played Place Terry silver actually
has a lot of experience using swords
when trying to figure out the next big
fight scene he just went up to the
creators and said hey what if we did a
sword fight I'm really good at swords he
didn't think they'd actually do it
because it's actually really dangerous
to film with swords but to his surprise
they ended up going for it they're
putting us in a pool outside when it's
freezing cold and you go oh my God all
these senses are firing I'm so excited
about this this is life and death and
I'm not afraid to die number five
through adversity comes great reward
once we were set up in those characters
we couldn't do the switching in and out
zelkey couldn't step in for Mary during
the fight scene at any point Mary had to
be able to perform every move so I
actually got to learn all the movements
with the bow staff I actually got to
learn the movements with the size so
basically Mary and the rest of the cast
get paid every day to learn karate it
feels like a dream which I guess it
literally is number six this was a very
big day on set going into season five we
knew we were going to have Daniel
Larusso fight Terry silver but after a
few takes the showrunners were concerned
Ralph Macchio who plays Daniel was
taking a lot on physically they were
about ready to call it a day but Ralph
said he wanted to do one more we watched
and he called his shot this
he called a shot and and uh he delivered
that was the one that ended up in the
Final Cut rule number three
a man can't see he can't fight
number seven almost like getting paid to
take a vacation the first two episodes
show Miguel looking for his father in
Mexico which is actually Puerto Rico as
Johnny and Robbie follow after him while
dealing with their own personal
struggles Williams abka who plays Johnny
loved the time he got to spend filming
on the island if it were up to me I
would film the entire next season of
Cobra Kai in Puerto Rico and not only
did cholo maraduena who plays Miguel
shoot his Cobra Kai scenes on the island
but he got to return for his leading
role in Blue Beetle when he got you that
way he didn't just snap your elbows his
shoulder oh okay number eight Daniel
just can't catch a break so that wasn't
an arm break I guess I guess it was not
an outbreak this fight scene wasn't an
easy one to choreograph they really took
their time trying to find the right
beads as they wanted it to be authentic
to their character's history it's always
got a play to what's going on
narratively story-wise character a man
can't stand
you can't fight so for that scene that's
Larusso unhinged number nine or rather
lack thereof truant because we're all
terrible at like actually coordinating
and showing up to one thing at the same
time apparently it's hard to get this
cast to form an ensemble there's always
like two of us missing but honestly with
all the stunts and intense fighting they
do we're not surprised they need a
little extra sleep in the mornings pain
sometimes
has a call time at the same time as me
and we both don't show up at that call
time number 10. a lot of training went
into the making of this show
and yeah emotional you know damaged all
for you since the actors do the majority
of their own stunts they wanted to do as
much as they could outside of the Cobra
Kai set in order to really sell it not
only being regulars at the gym but
things like karate and kickboxing were
becoming a regular form of habit I was
starting to go to a karate class and I
was also doing some training on over
Zoom Griffin Santo Pietro only started
his off the clock training after season
four I got the message in season four
when Dallas beat me up I was like okay
all right I gotta start doing this it
also helps that they all train with
their stunt doubles so everyone is
always on the same page when it comes to
the physicality of the scenes number 11.
the only time Mary Mouser breaks
character I can think of several times
where like it's usually involves a bug
lying near me and me panicking and
running off her biggest opponent was the
angry wasp waiting outside her trailer
door and she's like Jesse one of our one
of our Jesse Jesse Jesse Jesse is the
same guy who also pulled Mary's thumb
back into place after he heard it pop on
set Jesse one of our stunt guys uh runs
over to me and he was like look I was a
fireman for years I've heard that sound
but unfortunately he didn't save the day
this time and then all of a sudden it
just flies in
no amount of training could have
prepared her or I went all the way
number 12. the big question was always
when will they show up it's always fun
to find places for the Legacy characters
of course if you ever wanted a rematch
you know where to find me but it's
always crucial to us that they show up
at the right time people were most
curious about Mike Barnes played by Sean
cannon from Karate Kid Part 3. the
showrunners knew once Terry silver
showed up they could bring Mike in
shortly after Mike Barnes foreign
with all these incredible performers
fight sequences new characters and
weapons brought into the world of Cobra
Kai all of those things and so all of
those themes are kind of in this season
we're already excited to see what season
six will bring they have fun you know
they have fun give us your theories in
the comments